welcome everybody my name is Professor
Brian Keating and I am the proprietor of
the Dr Brian Keating into the impossible
podcast and YouTube channel so we're
going to be doing this every so often
impossible questions segment and I hope
you'll enjoy it and you'll send in
questions to the Instagram and or
Facebook group drinking Bros nerds and
other uh sessions that we can access and
I will read the questions and I'm
probably quarterly basis and we'll
hopefully get some really stimulating
answers and questions back and forth the
first question comes from Rena Friedman
Watts who asked how did it get
permission to go to Antarctica
Antarctica is an interesting place to do
cosmology that's where I do some of the
projects that I work on including the
bicep 2 project which I talk about in my
book losing the Nobel Prize not winning
it and that takes place at the bottom of
the world Antarctica and not only
Antarctica but also the South Pole so
the only people that can do work in
Antarctica are scientists or support
staff engineer ears plumbers contractors
Carpenters Etc and can actually apply to
be a worker there in the summertime or
the winter time in Antarctica and you
can get there the same way I did which
is by a military cargo plane the first
time I went down I got to the coast of
Antarctica via the New Zealand Air Force
which operates a fleet of our finest
C-130 cargo planes without any windows
or bathrooms and that's fun to be in but
at least you only have to be in them for
about 11 hours to make the one-way trip
from Christchurch New Zealand down to
McMurdo Station although I got to do it
two times in a row when my first flight
Boomerang it went down the weather was
too bad to land in Antarctica and so
actually they go down and then you turn
around more than halfway past the
halfway point because they want to
maximize the chances you can get there
and we didn't make it and so we actually
don't have enough fuel to make it back
to Christchurch so they had to land in
the southern tip of the southern island
in a place called Dunedin refuel this
massive four-engine turbo prop and and
fuel it up for the 30-minute flight from
Dunedin to Christchurch that was a
hellish day I'm not going to lie so the
answer is you need to get permission and
the way I got permission is through the
National Science Foundation which
operates the aircraft once you land in
Antarctica and what's interesting is
that we only own to the extent that we
quote unquote own real estate in
Antarctica because we're doing
scientific research there it's forbidden
to do commercial military operations
besides Transportation you can go down
there as a tourist you can pay about
fifty thousand dollars to so-called ski
the last degree
to get on a pair of cross-country skis
and ski the 60 nautical miles from 89
degrees south latitude to the South Pole
where you might be given a cookie or two
in the station then you're asked
gently cordially to please pack your
bags and leave because we don't want to
take on the responsibility of protecting
you but it is a glorious place maybe
we'll put in some pictures or some
videos that you can find on my channel
my talks about my book losing the Nobel
Prize I go through the kind of
travelogue portion of what it's like to
go to the South Pole and how we actually
got permission to do it so it's again
thanks to the taxpayers and that
actually allows me to thank you guys out
there because without your support as
taxpayers we signed not a single
scientist in America would be able to do
what he or she does without taxpayer
support and my joke is that it's kind of
my moral obligation and other scientists
to communicate in language regular
people can understand and this is part
of the way I'm going to do it leveraging
the awesome influence of the Bros to
impact as many people as we can around
the world to experience the passion of
oh always being curious thank you arena
for that question
thank you very much for tuning in to
this episode of impossible answers with
yours truly Dr Brian Keating
Chancellor's distinguished professor of
physics and co-director of the Arthur C
Clarke Center for human imagination at
the University of California San Diego
check me out on my YouTube channel Dr
Brian Keating subscribe to my podcast
the into the impossible podcast please
leave ratings reviews and all that that
really helps me out and we'll do more of
these hopefully like once a quarter
we'll compile your questions and I'll
hopefully give you some answers to
Impossible questions for now signing off
and thanking you very much for being a
part of my Multiverse this is yours
truly Professor Brian Keating